comment ça va TX
Amien alors j'ai une bonne nouvelle pour
vous ça va aller encore mieux dans 5
secondes êtes-vous prêt à une
expérience sensorielle
inoubliable non attendez je crois qu'on
s'est pas compris êtes-vous prêt à une
expérience sensorielle
inoubliable merci je vais vous inviter
si vous voulez bien à fermer les
yeux en a qui
triche
installez-vous confortablement au fond
de votre
siège posez vos mains sur vos
cuisse
détendez-vous relâchez la
tension maintenant avec moi vous allez
prendre trois grandes respirations en
inspirant par le nez et en expirant par
la
bouche
ça y est vous êtes tendu
maintenant j'aimerais que vous imaginiez
que nous sommes en plein hiver il fait
très très
froid pensez maintenant à une maison al
il peut s'agir de de votre
maison de la maison de votre enfance
de la maison de vos grands-parents une
maison de
campagne peu importe une maison où vous
avez de merveilleux
souvenirs
maintenant
imaginez-vous dans une pièce de cette
maison l'endroit que vous
préférez confortablement
installé c'est bon vous y
êtes vous sentez une bonne odeur de
biscuit sortant du four il s'agit d'une
Madeline préparé avec amour et qui vous
rappelle les
parfums de votre
enfance vous croqueer dans cette
Madeleine c'est
bon même très bon mais vous vous dites
qu'il manque un petit quelque chose pour
que cette Madeleine devienne
inouiliiable justement maintenant pensez
à votre agrume préférée un citron une
orange une
mandarine un citron vert celui que vous
aimez par-dessus tout avec votre roule
vous allez gratter des catement le zest
de cette
agrume portez le fruit à votre nez et
vous sentez l'odeur
décuplée continuez à gratter le ZA de
cette agrume avec votre ongle jusqu'à ce
qu'une petite goutte perle au bout de
votre doigt cette goutte est d'une
puissance incroyable un concentré
extrême faites tomber cette petite
goutte sur votre Madeleine et déguster à
nouveau waouh tel un magicien vous venez
de
sublimer cette Madeleine en une seule
goutte je vais vous invité à ouvrir les
yeux alors c'était bien
moi j'en ai vu en train de pleurer je
suis pas
balancé vous voyez avec un petit peu
d'imagination et votre ongle vous venez
de créer comme je l'ai fait il y a plus
de 20 ans la nouvelle génération d'arô
ces petites gouttes végétales ont changé
ma vie elles sont mon métier mon
expertise ma passion je m'appelle Emer
Pau je suis expert en huile essentielle
et twisteeur de
recette la cuisine est une vocation chez
moi je suis comme oblix je suis tombé
dedans quand j'étais petit et j'ai vite
senti qu'elle provoquait des émotions
incroyables chez l'être humain et j'ai
aussi vite senti que ça allait devenir
ma manière
d'expression ma manière d'exprimer mes
sentiments c'est dimanche matin je me
lève
il est 9h bon alors je suis un ado donc
je suis sorti la veille avec les copains
en mobylette faire le tour du village
donc du coup il est plutôt midi que 9h
je je passe dans la cuisine et là je
vois mon père en train de P des petites
carottes pour préparer son fameux bœuf
bourgignho mon père
est originaire de la creuse profonde
très très profonde et comme tous les
creusoir je pense de sa
génération il a je pense beaucoup de mal
à exprimer ses sentiments mais moi je
sait que par la cuisine il exprime ses
sentiments et notamment c'est sa façon
pudique de dévoiler son
amour moi la veille j'avais préparé des
religieuses au chocolat et au
café alors au chocolat pourquoi parce
que je savais que ça allait plaire à
tout le monde et au café parce que je
savais que c'était le parfum préféré de
mon
père et là mon père me regarde je le
regarde on se regarde quoi et il me
dit j'ai vu tes pâtisseries dans le
frigo c'est bien mon petit
gar je traduis je t'aime mon
fils ce qu'il y a de
passionnant c'est que je me suis rendu
compte qu'on pouvait exprimer son amour
dire je t'aime aux autres sans parler
juste en cuisinant non mais sérieux et
ben du coup
je suis devenu
cuisinier mais bon je vous rassure je
sais aussi dire je t'aime aux autres par
les mots j'ai ma femme qui est là donc
je peux lui dire je t'aime mon amour
sans
problème la cuisine et surtout les
ingrédients enfin la nourriture à
quelque chose de rassurant quelque chose
de
réconfortant ma fille qui a 3 ans il y a
quelques jours
c'est V trit lamentablement dans notre
jardin et elle vient me voir en me
disant bye je fais mal au genou je lu
dis bah ma chérie tu veux un câlin ouis
j'ai mal au
genou je sais pas tu veux un un bisou
magique tu veux un
chocolat et là on peut pas me dire que
la nourriture et la cuisine non'ont pas
un pouvoir magique un pouvoir
un
croyable en
2002 sur lit de la Réunion j'ai j'ai
découvert les huiles essentielles et ça
a vraiment changé ma vie tellement
changé ma vie qu'en 2004 j'aiété le
premier à écrire un ouvrage consacré à
la cuisine aux huiles essentielles avec
un nom
absolument créatif la cuisine aux huiles
essentielle et à ce moment-là je me suis
dit tiens je vais aussi créer la
nouvelle génération d'arôme avec ces
petites gouttes végétales bah là depuis
tout à l'heure on parle d'huile
essentielle mais mais au fait qu'est-ce
qu'une huile essentielle une huile
essentielle c'est une extraction à la
vapeur d'eau des essences secrété
naturellement par les
plantes ça fait un peu sérieux comme
définition en gros c'est un super super
super concentré de plantes et comment
fabriqueton ces magnifiques huiles
essentiell ben grâce à un alambique et
un alambique c'est ça alors la Lambique
vous savez tout ce que c'est pourquoi
parce que on fait aussi de l'alcool avec
VO de l'alcool fort même très très très
fort donc le principe c'est on met dans
cette petite cuve des plantes avec de
l'eau on fait chauffer l'eau qui se
transforme
en il y en a tris qui suivent super
l'eau est refroidie dans ce serpentin et
à la fin on récupère l'huile essentielle
qui surnage dessus au sue ce qu'on
appelle l'eau
florale et pourquoi justement utiliser
des huiles essentielles dans la
cuisine parce qu'on peut aromatiser en
une seule goutte n'importe quelle
préparation et surtout on a accès à une
créativité sans limite la sensation
d'être un aventurier du goût une espèce
d'Indiana Jones des saveurs et ça
vraiment ça aussi c'est quelque chose de
d'important pour moi parce que ça a
vraiment euh changé aussi ma
vie hein ah
Beni comment pu oublier cette fameuse
glace à lilangilang j'ai créé
euh je me souviens justement de cette
cette création incroyable une glace à
luuile essenelle lilangilang alors
l'ilangilang c'est une fleur exotique
incroyable qui a des parfums
entre le jasmin et et la vanille et
quand j'ai fait déguster cette glace
au aux personnes de mon nos clients au
personn au clients de mon premier
restaurant sur l de la Réunion il y a 20
ans j'ai découvert ce qu'était l'effet
waouh c'est un mélange de
gourmandise
d'étonnement et justement à ce moment-là
je me suis tiens je vais trouver un
glacier qui m'a
fabriqué cette glace pourquoi parce
qu'elle était unique au monde et qu'elle
avait provoqué une émotion
aussi unique au
monde désormais j'accompagne les
entreprises dans leur création de
recettees dans leur sublimation de
recette j'essaie de les convaincre que
que l'aromatisation peut-être à la fois
gourmande à la fois végétale et aussi
écologique alors écologique pourquoi un
petit exemple pour
faire 1 L d'huile essentielle de rose il
faut une tonne de pétales de rose donc
est-ce qu'il vaut mieux transporter 1 kg
ou une
tonne bon assez parler de d'huile
essentielle maintenant si on passait à
une petite
dégustation
des des madeleines vous vous êtes
distribuer voyez j'avais raison voyez
l'émotion que ça que ça provoque
cette
Madeleine a
été
fabriqué par une biscuiterie en
Normandie qui existe depuis 1850 et je
pense que c'est peut-être le spécialiste
mondial de la Madeleine c'est quelqu'un
que j'accompagne depuis une dizaine
d'années sur leur
création et cette Madeleine a été twisté
avec une huile
essentielle
mystérieuse donc là je vais vous inviter
à déguster la Madeleine alors ce que
vous pouvez faire c'est le faire les
yeux fermés en imaginant l'hiver la
maison le feu de
cheminée et j'ai deux questions pour
vous la
première quelle est cette huile
essentielle
mystérieuse
et la deuxième combien de gouttes
avons-nous utilisé pour fabriquer ces
madeleines vous pouvez donner des
réponse il y a pas de mauvaise
réponse la
r
alors
alors étonnamment ah très bien alors
l'ER de bison ça a plutôt le goût de fè
de tonka et de d'esragon je peux me
permettre
alors j'ai entendu des bonnes réponses
voilà donc il s'agit d'une huile
essentielle de feuill de Géranium
Bourbon donc on ne dis pas le la fleur
mais la feuille l'huile essentielle de
Géranium Bourbon est disilée sur l'île
de la Réunion et elle a des fragrances
des goûts entre le lichi et la
rose
et
donc j'ai une dernière question pour
vous quelle émotion
ressentez-vous d'avoir goûter une
madeleine avec une saveur unique au
monde
j'espère en tout cas
avoir touché vos esprits autant que vos
[Applaudissements]
sens